the mainstream media really does want
Trump and that is very very obvious
right Trump feeds the mainstream media
he tells you CNN is fake news and then
he does a town hall with CNN he tells
you it's the failing New York Times and
then he gives Maggie Haberman endless
access uh and they love it because what
does it do it gets them ratings and when
they get ratings and Views they get
money so this is really wild I saw this
video on Twitter a trump was mentioned
yesterday on CNN from what were the time
stamps on this from like within an
eight-hour span something like that what
is it 9 A.M to 6 p.m from 9 A.M to 6 PM
you know how many times they said the
name Trump
399 times here's just a little snippet
hello and welcome to inside politics
well let's start with Donald Trump
Donald Trump now of course Donald Trump
Trump trump Donald Trump trump appointed
Donald Trump well that's interesting
because Trump Trump trump president
Trump Donald Trump Trump trump Donald
Trump Donald Trump has been president
president Trump Caitlyn where are we
right now in this sentencing proceeding
Donald Trump Trump trump we have a
Donald Trump Donald Trump when it comes
to Donald Trump trump and uh Trump
Donald Trump missing from that is Donald
Trump you know Trump trump focus on
Donald Trump Trump trumpism trump a lot
of Trumps all right so 399 times and you
might go well why are they doing that I
thought they hate Trump I think I just
laid it out and you get it they want
Trump for a couple reasons it's not just
for the clicks and the views but I
firmly believe that they believe Trump
is the more beatable candidate and
DeSantis is refusing to play ball with
them uh here is a journalist by the name
of Jennifer Jennifer Palmieri on MSNBC
saying that Trump is more electable than
DeSantis do you think she might want to
push that notion so that Trump gets
nominated and then loses do you think
are you a wizard take a look
definitely no touch there's no
calibration with the guy and it's like
he started off you know he could have
just been an effective governor of
Florida and be doing well with the
Republican voters that want to move on
from Trump but instead he like re just
like double triple quadruple down on a
very mean-spirited
pretty nasty Maga agenda that I don't
think you know I mean
six-week abortion ban what are you doing
I'm not sure I think I could argue
Donald Trump is more electable than Ron
DeSantis when you support a six-week
abortion ban and his whole thing is
supposed to be he's the Electoral one I
mean that alone but then the totality of
the nastiness of that Maga agenda
marginalizing kids putting migrants sure
we should also we should the border is a
national problem and all all of us
should all of us agree all of us should
um you know partake in in dealing with
that
see guys they can't even hide it they're
saying the quiet part out loud first off
this idea that the scientist is somehow
nasty like it's just it's just so
ridiculous and that somehow he's the one
going after kids he's the one stopping
these butchers from chopping the
genitals off kids I would say that's
fairly Pro kid
[Music]
thank you